[Music]
i'm dave rubin and it's time for another
friday panel extravaganza today we're
going to be talking about whether things
are actually getting
back to normal in 2021 as the mainstream
media promised us
joining me today are political
commentator and former reuben report
guest lauren chen
chief video director of the daily caller
richie mcginnis
and host of the news and why it matters
on blaze tv
sarah gonzalez welcome to the reuben
report everybody
thanks for having us all right so i
thought an interesting way to start
would be as you guys know i am here in
crazy los angeles uh
as uh sarah you're of course in dallas
texas
sane dallas texas lauren you are in
completely bananas montreal canada
although you were just in florida
and richie you are in the isolated
desolate dc so i thought that would be a
good place to start that we are all in
very
different places at the moment sarah i'm
going to go to you first because you're
in a free
happy place how's that going for you
yeah you know it's interesting because
uh i was just discussing this um off-air
you have people
come in and visit and they're just they
don't know what to do when they see
people's full faces
they don't know what to do when they go
to a restaurant and people are relaxed
and
happy and laughing and they're like what
is this weird
world where people are laughing right
now and smiling it's very bizarre and i
think i've actually been
a little bit spoiled with it because it
really hadn't occurred to me
until we had all of these out-of-towners
come in how awful it is everywhere else
um so you know i feel bad for taking it
for granted and now of course our mask
mandate
has officially been lifted and i have
seen a lot of the businesses that i've
been going to
that have been slowly removing their
signs from their windows
so all good here all good here richie
i was in dc in december and it truly it
looked
like the beginning of a zombie
apocalypse it was completely locked down
to the point
that the only people i saw on the street
basically were homeless people that's
not really an exaggeration
yeah you're actually pretty correct
there sadly a lot of the businesses are
still boarded up here which is
just crazy that you know they've been
boarded up for almost a year now
and now we're back to we got indoor
dining so that's a big step just in time
for the end of winter
but uh also there's this capital fence
which is there
and you know thousands of national guard
so there's
not really any tourists in dc i mean
there have been a lot of i think
families coming out
kind of on the weekends at the mall but
it's during the week it's really just a
somber place
not a lot of the businesses are opened
up like half the bars
that i used to frequent or shuttered so
it's
it's a little bleak out here and it's
raining today and what are the national
guard defending against again
because it's unclear to me at this point
it's well it's unclear to me too because
their
rifles actually don't have uh magazines
in them
so it seems to be more of a message than
anything else
and obviously i was i was out here on
march 4th which was supposed to be
i guess you call it a q day or whatever
whatever
that everyone in the media was calling
it turned out to be a complete nothing
burger
despite the media talking about it for
the entire week leading up to it
and uh you mentioned the homeless
actually
i was on tucker last week discussing or
two weeks ago discussing
the situation in dc and i pointed out uh
a homeless man that i
interviewed who was actually fortifying
his tent literally right next to the
capitol fence
and he was he told me that he was told
by a park police that he wouldn't be
molested if he went there he would he
wouldn't be harassed by law enforcement
so that there's basically a homeless
encampment right next to that fence
in front of the capitol trust me we got
plenty of that in l.a if you build a
physical structure on public property
they have decided they just won't do
anything so we've got homeless people
that are
that are actually building compounds at
this point lauren
you were tweeting from florida and
people know when i tweet from florida
i'm very happy that's happy yeah now i'm
back in la dave but you were very happy
in florida
you're back in montreal montreal is
crazy right now it is crazy i mean
i was just telling you all earlier that
uh we we have had our 8 p.m curfew now
kind of
put forward until 9 30 p.m wow big deal
total freedom land over here uh but yeah
gyms are i think finally gonna start
reopening uh dining is still a no-go
they're
only doing takeout and it's just it was
such a difference going to florida i so
needed that just
mentally and i know like sarah was
saying i was one of those weird people
who didn't know how to act in the
normal world anymore i was at an event
and there was a waiter who was passing
around food and i was like can i take
this like what do i
do where do i sanitize my hand and it it
was just nice to be around normal people
and i
i'm actually i'm heading right back out
tomorrow back to florida hopefully do
some house hunting because i can't take
this
anymore i'm like at the end of my row do
you guys think
normalcy or normality those are the two
words they keep telling
us they promised this was going to be
the year we got back to normality that's
what
the infallible fouchy says all the time
do you think normal whatever that means
once we actually do basically fully open
up
do you think anything resembling the
world of pre-2020
is coming back richie
um i don't really think so no i mean i
think there are certain
you know things that kind of the
pandemic made people realize makes sense
like you know going to the office every
day
uh we used to go to the caller newsroom
literally we had to be there by 8 am
and we had to be out by you know maybe
five or six
so the caller's productivity actually
has gone up in terms of the reporters
and how much they're writing
just because they're spending more time
working and less time you know commuting
and doing all those types types of
things involved with uh
getting the office in dc i mean the
metro is is definitely no fun
so i think in that respect you know
there are some positive changes but
in terms of the government control i
mean we saw the same thing happen after
9 11
uh the patriot act as far as i'm
concerned i don't
think that that's been uh pulled back at
all since
it was written in the early 2000s and i
think we're gonna
see a similar situation here which is
that you know a lot of the control that
the government has over where we go
and um what exactly we're doing well
that'll remain
yeah richie it has the word patriot in
it so that automatically means it's good
don't you know that
if you hate it you hate america too much
lauren what do you think you think we're
gonna ever get to something
somewhat i don't even care for the word
normal that much normal ain't that great
but just something that feels a little
better than
this new thing well what really worries
me
is that they keep moving the goalposts
as to when we can start to open back up
and have
like reclaim more of our freedoms right
do you i mean it was two weeks to slow
the spread
and you know then it was talking about
oh well we we want to get like over the
first hump
and then it was talking about like oh
well we want to get past flu season
because we don't want it to you know
flu plus covid and then it was until the
vaccines and now it's like we have
vaccines people are being vaccinated
they're saying yeah well we're still
going to even with vaccination need to
wear masks and social distance now
people are talking about
covet passports to travel places and
enter businesses and it's like i don't
i think there are people out there who
have a vested interest in keeping things
the way that they are whether it's for
control or financial means
well whatever and so i think if we do
want to get back to like quote unquote
normal
we're actively going to have to fight it
because it's like with the income tax
once the government puts on a new
restriction it's very very rare that
they just
you know willfully give it up sarah our
buddy glenn beck is always talking about
this the sort of ever encroachment of
government and that there's a lot of
people who gained a lot of power
during this thing and they probably
don't want to give it back and this was
just the beginning
yeah and that's what i kept trying to
warn people of whenever we did go
through 15 days to slow the spread is
hey guys
do you recall a time in history where
the government has willingly just
relinquished the control that they have
already taken they never take it back we
see them constantly fight that all they
want is more and more and more
and you know of course that fell on deaf
ears at the time because everyone was so
panicked and scared
of you know the promisings of a virus
that was going to wipe us all off the
face of the planet
so here we are a year later and of
course they're not going to give it back
willingly that's why
you know we've seen the teachers unions
fight actually going back to work
and teaching the children that's why
we've seen so many things keep going
just as lauren mentioned you know we
have
a vaccine now and even if you get the
vaccine they warn you that you still
have to wear a mask and you still have
to socially distance and you can't
actually get back to normal life
what were you thinking once you got the
jab you were actually going to be able
to live life again
please that's not the case so i think
that it really is i agree with lauren
that it's going to take
us really moving and shaking things and
letting the government know we will not
accept this for us to get some aspects
back to normal
but i also do agree with richie that i
think that there are
certain aspects of this that maybe
private businesses have learned
hey maybe we are more functional
operating this way
i know that doesn't that's not the case
for every industry
but i think that you know private
businesses are much different
than government control and
unfortunately we are going to have to
move
mountains uh to fight them on this but i
think that we will i think that the
american public is increasingly getting
fed up with all of this government
control all of the double speak
and i think eventually i don't think it
will happen this year uh but i think
eventually
it will happen yeah i was just going to
say sarah one of the benefits of where i
live
this whole kobe thing has finally kicked
my grocery store into gear and allowed
us to have delivery so
online delivery for our groceries yeah
so i essentially never need to leave the
house which
usually would be a good thing for me but
now it's it's been so long where i'm
like okay but now i want to leave the
house
well and and and texas too uh during
this whole thing
they finally made legal to go alcohol
orders
which has been tremendous for me so you
know i was pregnant and now i'm not
anymore and i'm really enjoying the the
to go alcohol delivery right so as since
i think we have at least one
one 20 year old in here rough in the 20s
one at least one in the 30s i think i'm
the elder statesman here in the 40s but
we've got
we've got three generations or three
decades covered here
um i'm worried that just the that
basically i always say
to to my producer and my director who
are in their early 20s like
you guys are going to be the last people
to ever remember
the old world as adults that if you're a
15 year old growing up as this
in this thing it's like you're not going
to remember that world that now seems so
precious and kind of long gone to us
are you worried about that richie yeah i
i know we were talking a lot about the
government control and i did mention
that some businesses
you know there are positive effects but
i think the most concerning thing to me
actually and what i saw you know at all
these protest zones over the last year
is the real human suffering that's
resulted as um from this
massive transfer of wealth from
basically small businesses that you know
were open and thriving
prior to the pandemic and now are
completely shuttered i used to bartend
for years in dc
and like all my friends who i used to
bartend with like have just basically
been on unemployment this entire time
and so that's what's most concerning to
me is it's it's easy for us
you know working in the media we've
continued to work but
you know all these people sitting in
their studios basically telling
everybody to stay at home and slow the
spread
it's they're not the ones losing their
jobs in these situations and those are
the people that i've seen out on the
street
and like actually seeing that you know
that human suffering acted out through
um protest and and civil unrest is
really it's heartbreaking to see
yeah where where do you think the
general state of
critical race theory identity politics
all the stuff that i know the four of us
have been yelling about
for years that now kind of everyone gets
where four years ago everybody was like
oh no it's just on college campuses
it's not it's not real it's not really
gonna happen um
how do you think that plays into the
fact that we're all so disconnected and
stuck online because i think it has a
big
role in it sarah what do you think yeah
i would agree with you
and um i would also say that you know
when we're looking at
um you know our our children like i have
an eight-year-old son and i'm thinking i
don't know what he's going to remember
about this particular time in history
and then i've got a very young baby
and i'm thinking to myself how is life
going to be so different for him
uh you know we have this generation
who's growing up
with you know learning the teachings
that you're talking about critical race
theory identity politics but also
growing up in a time of government
control and i think that that really
shapes your perspective any time
like i remember when um you know we had
the first graduating class of
people who had not remembered 9 11.
and it really shapes your perspective
not actually living through these events
not remembering these events i remember
these people
it was so foreign to them the idea that
you know we could have that kind of
uh terrorism happening on our own soil
to that extent and so i think you're
going to see the same thing taking place
with these children um richie i'm not
calling you a child but
with the the other children um
31 yeah lauren am i allowed to ask you
how old you are i am 26 i don't mind
okay okay lauren's the baby then
lauren's the baby
so not calling you a child yes not
calling you a child lauren but
um i think that we are going to see a
lot of people growing up
who do scare this is scary to say but
they don't know
anything else other than big government
control
other than the government making up
their mind for you other than the
government saying the science is settled
therefore the science is settled
other than the government saying the
critical race theory
is the you know this is what we're
learning and this is what they know and
they won't know anything else and it
really really scares me
you know especially like i said having
two young children it really scares me
but i fear that that is where we're
headed because that's just what happens
when you don't have that kind of
perspective you haven't lived through it
i mean it can't shape your narrative it
can't shape your perspective and
unfortunately i think that's where we're
headed
so lauren you're the youngest on the
panel you're the kid here what's going
on with the young people in the midst of
this
well i think sarah's exactly right the
way you grow up really does
influence what you think is acceptable
and i know i've even seen like gen zires
on twitter
argue that oh no going to churches
that's not a right
like yeah it's like a right but it
doesn't mean you have to do it or that
it's essential it's like ah
founding fathers would disagree like
they're actually trying to argue that
rights are non-essential
um no it's terrifying and recently uh
you know i
i met with this other young couple and
they had a baby or a toddler who i think
was about
two and you know the kid was wide-eyed
looking at this crowd of people and he
said oh sorry like he's a coped baby
this is
the most people he's ever seen in his
life and think about that like there are
like children who are who were born like
last year and they've like really never
seen more than maybe
uh four people in a room together
because they haven't been allowed to get
that exposure to see their extended
family members
it is just so sad and you know the
people who
are like all for shutting down schools
and these social events in the name of
saving people i don't think they
appreciate the cost of like richie was
saying
um keeping these lockdowns going and
as someone who i'm hoping that like
within the next year i'll have at least
one kid of my own
i i'm really worried and that's like
part of why i i'm thinking i just can't
stay in a place where
i'm not gonna be able to raise my kid in
a normal environment it's terrifying
yeah let's shift a little bit to the
media portion of this because
i know all you guys love to critique the
media as much as i do
richie you work for the daily caller
right before we started
i retweeted the daily caller because i
think you guys
do something close to what was known as
journalism once
there ain't much of it left um how bad
do you think
uh mainstream media is at this point
well it's actually interesting because i
started uh basically
working in the professional like media
in 2013
so i was working at nbc uh from 2013 to
2015
and then i actually went uh from nbc to
mark levin so i kind of
flipped on the ideological spectrum but
you know back then i think things
weren't the way that they are now in
terms of the way
that everything that comes out of either
joe biden's white house or previously
trump's white house is just viewed
through this lens of
it it's either you know it's it's you're
either on this side or that side
and that kind of like you know trench uh
warfare approach to media is something
that i think is is a new phenomenon
and i i think the daily caller one of
the reasons why i ended up working here
is because
our role in the media landscape is very
much to to put that in check and to
you know try our best to call out when
media narratives don't match uh the
reality of the situation so
you know obviously that whole uh cue uh
insurrection phenomenon i mean that was
just that was completely made up um
and you know my city has been shut down
for all this time as a result and my
friends are all unemployed so i don't
take it very lightly at all
yeah uh sarah you're over there in
dallas with my buddies at the blaze who
are actually
doing something reminiscent of old
school journalism and trying to analyze
stuff honestly do you think they're just
pushing
more and more people to us at this point
like it's hard to gauge
how much influence they actually have at
this point i'm always saying on the show
it's like
i feel like i have to talk about cnn and
correct their nonsense
and on the other hand i'm like ah maybe
if we just stop talking about them
maybe nobody's really paying attention
yeah i mean i would agree i think i just
saw
a uh a headline fly by me when i was
looking on my phone earlier about cnn
having
such low ratings uh post-trump which was
what was so peculiar about them wanting
trump to be out of office as i'm i'm
like
guys this is why your ratings are as
good as they are and that's not even to
say that they're good
it's just that this is all that you can
talk about what's going to happen when
he leaves and so
i think that we're seeing that and i
think that for as much as we love to
talk about i mean
big tech has its problems and i'm not
here to tell you that they don't
um but one at least silver lining
of having social media around of having
the twitter and the facebook and all of
these places you can go to
is that we actually get these tidbits of
the truth we get to see these videos
that aren't played on the news
uh you know and i think that that has
been really important for opening up
people's eyes and having them realize
wow maybe the media isn't telling us the
truth but i will say i think that it is
that i think the media right now is
going through this internal
battle um and i think it'll be
interesting to see how it plays out
because while we saw that
obviously their common goal was to get
trump out of office and they were
successful in that goal
now they're faced with either continuing
to carry water for the democrat party
and for a president who very obviously
you know i call him the dementia patient
in chief he very obviously
does not belong in the position that
he's in so they can either continue
carrying water knowing that that's
probably not the right move
or um they can turn themselves into the
star into the celebrity and i wonder if
their narcissism is going to
to actually win out in the end and that
that's what we've been seeing with
they're actually some of them are
publishing stories about what's
happening on the border they're
publishing stories saying there's a 729
percent over
legal capacity of these migrant
facilities they're doing things that you
wouldn't normally see them do
because they want to make themselves the
story and the only way to do that now
that trump is out of office
is to actually do a certain level of
journalism
that i don't think that they're used to
doing so it'll be interesting to see how
that plays out
journalists being forced to do
journalism it's incredible
lauren you got to kind of be digging it
right like you're a new media star
like you're doing your thing you're free
you got to be happy watching them
crumble right
at least at a personal level i am
happy about that but it's also i mean
i've mentioned i'm pretty black-pilled
on most issues now and i think for a
while i was under the impression that
the media is just the most biased it's
ever been but i'm more and more starting
to think perhaps we're just more aware
of the bias and it's always been like
that i mean it's it's kind of hard to
say which might be the case
but definitely new media is filling a
role that i think more and more people
are
looking for because i think there are a
lot of people who for example with kobit
might turn on to cnn or something like
that and see all this panic panic
hysteria but then
look around at their own neighborhoods
or towns and cities and say okay well
our hospitals aren't actually
overflowing
but i do see unemployment going up and
then because of the disconnect that they
see between what the media is reporting
what they're seeing maybe
go seek out other forms of information i
hope that's what's happening and i think
at the very least we're going to be
seeing a decentralization
of media control but i mean at the end
of the day
i don't think we can kind of dismiss the
media yet entirely because if we look at
the
effect they had at the recent election
fiasco uh
you know they they still obviously have
a lot of establishment power they still
consider themselves the people who get
to call elections determine what is and
what is not a conspiracy theory so i
don't think we're out of the woods yet
from getting out of their control
election fiasco you're really trying to
get me booted from youtube
very clever trying to take out the
competition
very very very clever well i i like what
you said there though about that they're
trying to make us
uh be unable to see things that we can
see because i keep bringing up that
that one moment to me that crystallized
it so well
when when all the riots were happening
over the summer and ali velshi's
standing out there on msnbc
saying that these are largely
non-violent protests and there's a
building blowing up behind him and it's
like literally like it was in fallujah
like as if a bomb had just been dropped
and you know and he's telling us they're
largely
peaceful uh richie you guys believe
you're lying eyes thing
right yeah well that's it so how do you
guys decide what
is and what isn't important to actually
cover
because there's just so much so we
developed like we were talking a little
bit earlier about
um eli who works over at the blaze as
well but there was actually like a small
kind of
we call it the riot squad uh we traveled
around the country basically from
hotspot to hotspot because
there was so clearly such a blind spot
in the corporate media even like fox
news
you know you'd see their guys going out
there in chats and saying very much a
party-like atmosphere back to you
and then that you know that's at 2 p.m
uh maybe they they do one hit in prime
time
they have an entire security force and
they have these big cameras
and then they go back to their luxury
hotel and they're like yeah that's
what's going on
thanks back to you and so we would go
out there from
you know 2 p.m to 3 4 a.m
and just sit there and use our cell
phones you know very um
low-key fly on the wall and just show
america what was happening and
you know eli the first time i met him
was in the chas
and uh basically from there you know
everything you know the toothpaste came
out of the tomb i guess you can say that
but
it's funny you mentioned that uh the
velcro clip because actually
there was also the the cnn correspondent
in in kenosha
where the chiron that famous meme now
fiery but mostly peaceful
yeah and you know we're talking about
the human suffering that's resulting
from
you know all these lockdowns and just
the shutting down of businesses and
all of the mental health health uh
byproducts of
basically people being shuttered up i
actually literally had
you know a mentally unwell person
literally die in my arms in kenosha
and so when i hear you know these these
narrative media narrative platitudes
about you know this protest or that
protest and they're really viewing them
through
their own partisan lenses be it trump
supporters uh
protesting or blm and for me like
i i view them as two different
uh parts of the same problem which is
this economic suffering
and people feel like they haven't they
don't have that american opportunity
that has always been you know the real
thing that binds us all together and if
we don't have that i don't know what we
have
yeah so we're not allowed to see things
that we can see with our own eyes
and at the same time sarah they'll tell
us that antifa is just an idea
and apparently an idea that's caused
about 2 billion worth of damage in the
last year
yeah it's interesting how an invisible
thing can just cause that much
uh in damages and i would agree with
richie that you know i think it's
important for
as alternative media outlets that we are
always at the places that the mainstream
media refuses to go
um but i also think that it's important
that and i think that we you know
i i know richie you guys over the daily
caller do a great job of this as well
but i think we've been great at blaze tv
about shining a light really on what's
going on um
in culture as well because as we know
politics is downstream from culture
and so you know we're it's funny because
i used to do
when i first started out i would do
these um
videos on breaking down you know let's
say the paris climate accords or break
you know breaking down
all of these big issues a tax bill or
whatever
and no one wanted to watch it because
at the end of the day as important as it
is to americans and it is very important
it's just it's not culture culture is
what moves people culture is really what
is going to move the needle and
i think that we've done a good job of
going where the mainstream media will
not go where the mainstream media will
say
well i mean that's not really important
and we look at that and go actually
it is because culture shapes politics
and um i you know again i think that the
mainstream media it's lost on them
that kind of idea um but i think that
that really is
what people are wanting to see i think
it's what is compelling to them and i
think it is what is going to
determine our direction as a country
especially right now we're at this
you know precipice of which direction
are we going to go
are we going to just blindly accept the
government telling us what to do
uh in conjunction with the mainstream
media or are we going to do this
research
uh independently and figure out that hey
maybe we should be standing up and
telling them enough is enough
and so um i think that it really is
important uh to
to keep getting those kinds of culture
stories out
to americans because i think it is
really is what's going to grab them and
move them
actually that's a perfect segue to where
i wanted to spend the last couple
minutes with you guys because obviously
the big story of the week was the
shooting at the massage parlors and
um lauren i think you've had a couple
tweets on this that i thought
were just perfect because there's sort
of two things happening at once which is
one is
is what happened this 21 year old kid
did shoot up people eight eight people i
believe were killed
but then that's sort of secondary to the
media narrative that everyone is
spinning now
about hate crimes and all and white
supremacy and
all the usual stuff that we endlessly
hear about so can you kind of sum up
where where you're at with all this
right now
uh where i'm at is frustrated i mean you
follow me on twitter you
can probably see that i've been having a
real hard time with all of these
i mean frankly white progressives uh
telling me
what it is like to be asian in america
and what type of
problems the asian community is facing
you know regarding the shooting it's
very
unfortunate what happened uh you know my
best wishes to the families victims and
all of that but from everything we know
from police that was not a racially
motivated crime and i think a lot of
people out there cannot distinguish
between
doing something to an asian person and
doing something to a person because they
are asian
and that's the narrative that
essentially we're seeing right now also
interesting is that there has been a
an uptick in anti-asian you know
assaults and things like that but the
media like you're saying is trying to
spin
this into a tale of white supremacy if
we actually look at who these
perpetrators are
they're disproportionately
african-american right so it's kind of
hard if you ask me to see a black person
attacking an asian person and
blame white people for it but that's
just where we are as a community
and i think what we see with all this
like moral indignation
from the left is they are trying to turn
the asian community
in into another reason why the white
supremacy
we see from the right or whatever is bad
and let me tell you
why that is such bs is that for the
longest time the left has completely
ignored or even
discriminated against asians frankly we
have seen asians get called white
adjacent
not real poc we are discriminated
against in progressive affirmative
action policies for being asian right
you can't have too many asians in school
because they're too successful
not only that we've also seen the left
fight very hard against merit-based or
skills-based immigration which does
disproportionately
benefit asian americans we've seen them
fight hard against lowering business
taxes and regulations which again asian
americans disproportionately
entrepreneurs and it's like
the left does not care one iota about
asians except for when they can use them
as political props
and it's been very insulting to hear
from progressives
how the hard work that my family has
gone
gone through to achieve the success they
have is really just marginalized by the
fact that we are white adjacent or
whatever it may be so it's just
it's a headache and i really understand
i put this out on twitter as well why it
is that
when you know a hispanic or a black
conservative speaks out against the woke
left they go the hardest it's because
you know they have to deal with this
pandering patronizing attitude all the
time
and i feel bad for them it's it's
frustrating yeah man
i mean you just you just hit pretty much
everything related to
all of this so so like yesterday on my
show we played the clip of jen pasaki
basically blaming trump's rhetoric and
then what we played right after it was a
great compilation that we found
of uh you know all these msnbc and cnn
journalists quote-unquote journalists uh
calling it the china virus and the wuhan
virus and everything else
uh not that that in and of itself is
causing racism right it's just the place
it's the city
that it came from in china we understand
all that uh but richie how do we flip
that narrative how do we get more people
i don't want everybody to be
black-pilled i want them to be
red-pilled first and then we'll work
with that
how do we how do we get them to flip on
that and go oh it's not just
racism and white supremacy there's
actually some other stuff going on here
all the things that lauren just
addressed
well i think you know that whole
knee-jerk reaction i think we've
obviously seen that over the last four
years
like a lot more of that and perhaps the
system was broken before that but it's
certainly gotten worse
but you know with respect to this most
recent shooting
i mean when i'm on the ground with our
folks we're basically telling
all of our reporters okay you'll get
more likes and retweets if you call
you know whoever's in black block a blm
rioting
terrorist right because the people who
want to see that kind of narrative spun
up will
you know retweet it but if you just call
them a protester
basically it's never very clear you know
even the word rioter implies that that
person went out there to riot
whereas a lot of times you know things
get a protest gets unruly and it gets
declared a riot
and it's not clear who gets caught up in
that that chaos and who
is actually out there with with bad
intentions so i always tell folks both
of the sides you know
also the same goes for uh during the
capital right same use the same term
protesters because it wasn't clear
you know to us i wasn't able to
interview these people and ask them you
know why they were there
and so in in that kind of chaos
you really you can't make these
assumptions it's extremely dangerous
and especially when you're dealing with
an american national tragedy
you can't just like throw around you
know charges of racism
just willy-nilly and i think we're at
that point and that's what's really
concerning to me is that like
you know the quote unquote establishment
corporate media used to be
the kind of purveyors of of fact
checking and you know using multiple
sources and no
no single source anonymous reporting
which we've seen a lot of recently so
i think this is just the latest
iteration of you know
after kyle rittenhouse that after that
shooting you know you saw the same thing
um happen and it's it's really more
about what narrative you want spun
up given whatever side you're on than it
is about you know the facts at hand and
just like how about you just wait for
them to play out and they basically are
politicians and the media they basically
don't get
they don't care when they get caught
red-handed like all of the politicians
and all of the media
members who said that the jessie
smallett thing what proof
that's proof we got the proof america is
a white supremacist nation
and then here they go again with this
story so sarah how do we communicate
this
to people you do a news show every day
how do you
how do you do it so that it's not just
the people watching
all four of us but like so that the
other people can really start
understanding
that most of the of the discrimination
in in any sort of tangible sense
actually is coming from the left these
days that's just the sad truth
well i think that unfortunately for the
left i think that they are
as they often do over playing their hand
in that
and i think that the you know we saw it
with the recent election now
um you know the the results were not of
course what i think all of us
would have liked for them to be but
there were still a record number of
you know um uh black americans
minorities um i think asian americans i
mean there were
record numbers of people who voted for
president trump who voted for
conservative ideals and i think that a
lot of that stems from the fact
that democrats have overplayed their
hand they show these people
that they're using them as pawns and the
ends justifies the means and i think
that the
more that they continue to do that the
more that they continue to show
that they are the divisive party and the
more that an average american
i think you know lauren mentioned this
uh regarding coronavirus but
the average american looks around and
goes well i don't i'm not a white
supremacist i don't know any white
supremacists
i don't personally know anyone who you
know is
is uh waging violence against asian
americans
the more they think about hold on this
isn't happening to me
or anyone around me is this really
accurate
combined with the more that the
democrats continue to just
overtly use people for political gain
i think that we're already seeing people
wake up i think that you know we're
already seeing
a lot of the minority communities say
we're tired of being used
i think that we're even seeing uh you
know parents
look around and say okay you're using my
children by keeping schools closed for
political gain
for teachers unions and i'm sick of it
and i think that the more that they play
these games with people because they're
so arrogant they don't think that they
will ever
a get found out and b get held to the
same standard that they hold everyone
else to
i think the more that they continue to
do that uh the more
americans will wake up because it's
actually affecting them and i think that
that's where
that's where it's really going to be
crucial is that once the american
the americans who are being fed this bs
once they actually
feel it and they feel the pain for
themselves i think it's really hard to
turn them away from being
uh you know as you would say red pilled
so what you're saying is
our work is cut out for us lauren i'm
gonna let you
bring us home here as as the one
panelist
potentially making the move to america
sell us
sell us on the dream give everybody i
know you said black pill before which
for my audience that doesn't know black
pill that's basically
after you've been red pill that you see
reality but then it's sort of the
depressing end of reality sort of
but give me something hopeful because i
i know you well enough lauren that you
couldn't do what you do
if if you believed it just could never
turn around like how could any of us
so bring us home well i was gonna close
with some more
doom and gloom but you know what you're
right let's leave it on a positive note
um for anyone who's just looking around
the world and wondering
when everyone went insane just know that
most people don't approve of this type
of stuff right most people aren't on
board with like oh yes let's have drag
queens
in schools reading to kids let's have
lockdowns and curfews at 8pm but what
the problem is that there is a small
group of ideologues who have managed to
insert and kind of weasel their way into
positions of power
and i think if us the i guess silent
majority normal sane people want to get
back to a point where
a discussion about politics is really
just about politics not these whole big
issues of white supremacy yada yada
um then we need to start standing up to
those bullies because i mean we're
essentially being held hostage
by a small number of full-time activists
and i'm sick of it
i'm sick of people having to worry about
what they tweet out and getting fired
because of it
uh you know i'm sick of brands having to
pander to this or that lobby i want that
return to
not just pre-covered normalcy but
pre-woke activism normalcy
and the only way that's going to happen
is if we start standing up to them
amen girl and listen if it doesn't work
out we'll uh we'll meet you at the
family compound in florida how does that
sound yeah everyone's invited
all right well for the record i voted
for kanye just for the record
wow 2024. all right thank you guys very
much i'm gonna finish up without you but
you guys
really appreciate you joining me and
have a good weekend everybody thanks you
too
thank you all right so thanks to lauren
to sarah
and to richie and for you guys i wanted
to you know i do it this way you know i
wanted to end on something
somewhat hopeful and not black-pilled
because i think there is a temptation
right now and you saw a little bit
out of me last week to just get so
frustrated with all this stuff and to
just wake up every day
and see what stupid thing happened what
depressing thing happened what thing of
the past that we all
loved is now evil while [ __ ] or whack
is the number one song in america or
played in the grammys or just all the
endless nonsense
but i totally agree with what lauren
said most people
are not like this they're not and that
also is the danger
of what's happened with the lockdowns
because we're becoming more and more
disconnected
from our neighbors you know we moved as
you guys know we moved uh houses which
is why i'm in a different studio than i
was
uh just a year ago in the middle of
lockdown
and i have obviously new neighbors
around here and finally we were walking
the dog the other day
and a neighbor was like oh you guys are
the new ones that moved in why don't we
have a drink
and it was just so refreshing for a
human being
we were standing on opposite sides of
the fence but like literally opposite
sides of the fence but it was like it
was so refreshing for another human to
be like oh
welcome and let's have a drink and let's
get to know each other
so i'm going to keep pushing that idea
let's keep getting to know each other
as i said i will be doing some live
stand-up we're working it out i don't
want to tease too much right now because
we're still trying to figure out a
little bit of the routing
uh but that should be for a couple days
uh in april
in florida we're going to do a live meet
up in oc
for all the the socal people and uh
let's fix this thing i have nothing
better to do i suspect you don't either
uh have a good weekend everybody and if
you want to see what i'm eating
and drinking and listening to and all
that good stuff join me at
reubenreport.locals.com all right see
you
you